you and i had some epic showdowns on
television you called it everything from
crypto garbage uh to one time you forbid
me from owning any more of it uh but i
think that there's a lot of changes that
have happened in the market both from a
regulatory standpoint and also some of
the market dynamics and you now are
comfortable starting to allocate to it
so maybe walk us through kind of what
changed and then how you're thinking
about allocating to a bitcoin of
cryptocurrencies today
yeah so what changed is exactly what you
said pomp the regulatory environment i
work in a very regulated world i'm an
investor in so many different financial
services companies that are reporting
issuers and so we don't have the luxury
of being offside with regulators not now
not ever and in 2017 when we were
talking about those epic moments and
it's true because i get those things
shoved in my face every day but but i
point out that when things change i
change
that's when i took my first bitcoin
ethereum positions in 2017. obviously
i've done very well with those but
recently after the regulators in
switzerland france germany australia
england
japan canada all started to change their
stance on crypto it allowed me to start
to allocate to it in a compliant way and
that's really what got me going
obviously this is an asset class that's
here to stay it's still going through a
very nascent phase i'll be putting a lot
more into it as time changes and still
the regulator's not 100 on board we all
know that but things are getting better
not just domestically but
internationally and so i'm an
international investor and in many
countries where we're talking about
bitcoin or ethereum or other assets
other other crypto assets tokens and
coins uh the regulators opened up
what's the current allocation percentage
i think at one point we talked and you
said you were at three percent are you
still at three
no i've i'm you know i'm i've told
everybody i've disclosed that by the end
of the year i'll probably be at seven
percent that's the target because i've
gone beyond ethereum and and bitcoin i
have a pretty big position usd right now
usdc i'm moving into some other assets
that i'm negotiating right now i have
been struggling with this esg issue
around uh mining my own coin as you
recall that topic was really forefront
at bitcoin 2021 when i i moderated and i
think you were there the the major
miners and how they're trying to deal
with this carbon offset issue i still
get people asking about that i still
haven't i still have
sovereign funds that i service to some
of my other companies asking what are
you going to do
around the csg because they have these
compliance committees and i know a lot
of people debate this issue but it's not
going away and so
i think you're going to see a real move
towards places like west texas
solar
wind ideas around new gen generation
where it's completely compliant
heidi i'm a shareholder in there now
jamie leverton does uh sustainable
mining with flare gas so i mean there's
there's ways to get around it pomp and
i'm using that to increase my allocation
but i think by the end of the year
across all crypto assets it'll be a
seven percent waiting and it could go as
high as 20 if i wanted to but i'm just
taking it one step at a time what would
it need to take or what would have to
happen for you to go from the seven
percent target today to 20 percent
performance
performance i mean that's basically you
know i'm not a cowboy here i'm actually
allocating capital towards achieving a
distributable return of between six and
eight percent a year and so you know we
have a lot of volatility in bitcoin and
right now we're kind of 61 back from the
lows and that's great but not every
crypto asset has to be that volatile so
when you start to build out your
portfolio let's go to usdc
you know
you actually can take that as a
relatively stable asset
and write contracts on it for 60 days 30
days 90 days and generate three and a
half four percent yield which is what
i'm doing right now and so i look at it
as a portfolio approach some of these
things have volatility some don't but
you know the biggest problem which is
holding all of us back in the crypto
industry right now
is compliance at the institutional level
you know you go in and you say look um
everybody's talking about this all right
i'm running let's say i'm running a
billion dollar mandate that's not
uncommon and i want to put 10 percent
into crypto
you have to be able to find a platform
that can link to your internal reporting
and your external regulatory you know
it's not like i got a 100 if i'm putting
a 10 allocation on a billion that's a
hundred million i'm not going to
download an app on my phone and put 100
billion 100 million dollars into it
i'm going to have to have an
institutional compliant platform and the
industry is not there yet pomp it's got
a lot of work to do on that front and
the more we move towards that the more
capitalism will be coming in how do you
think about the breakdown between
bitcoin
other coins and then what i'll call like
the miners or more publicly traded cash
flowing type businesses do you have a
framework as to how you're trying to
allocate across these
yeah the seven percent allocation is
allocated across all of the above let me
give you an example i talked about how
they have no you know i'm just a
shareholder and the reason
that i met jamie was when we were making
a reallocation to some of our office
space she took some of my office space
which i'm very proud to have done that
deal with her and we got to know each
other and i was i was telling her back
then it was a few months ago the
challenges i i was having coming out of
the bitcoin 2021 conference and all of
that that stuff about esg and which coin
do you own and all that she said well
look
i keep every coin that we mine at honey
it's sitting on the balance sheet every
time we get awarded a coin it stays
there i lend it out so i can get fiat
currency to pay my expenses but i own
the coin
so that you're going to trade my stock
in a very high correlation to the price
of bitcoin because the more i mine the
more it stands my balance sheet i'm a
proxy for the coin i said that's a very
interesting model i'm interested because
i know every coin you've got since you
started
has been built on a compliant basis
towards esg so i'll become a shareholder
so i bought some of her stock and the
stock is volatile as bitcoin is i think
i'm up 61 and bitcoin's up 61 since i
bought it so she's really starting to
trade with the value of her balance
sheet that interests me a lot to solve
for my mining issue because if i want
more allocation of mining i have no risk
of getting called out from compliance
around esg with hud-8 i'm not i don't
want to sound like an advertisement for
them but if more of the miners did what
she is doing you get more institutional
capital coming into the mining
infrastructure which we don't have right
now it's very hard to raise money for
mining infrastructure because if you've
got a facility in tennessee or
mississippi or something like that which
is not compliant because there's coal
energy there you get all these headaches
and that issue has not gone away yet so
i think that we talked about this last
time you were on the podcast uh my take
on it is the esg folks are i've lost
their minds they're putting all these
undue pressure and they don't really
understand bitcoin and mining and all of
that i think that you're trying to solve
not for uh what i'll call personal
belief and you're on some crusade
but more so from a compliance says i
have to do x i got to figure out a
solution so i can allocate capital to an
asset that i want to uh allocate to so
it's very much like you're giving a box
and you're trying to play within that
box right uh with that said well i pomp
i want i want to get detail on that i
have no choice i have it i have a
compliance department they have an
investment committee on top of that is
the sustainability committee and the
ethics committee i don't have a choice
there's no negotiation i got to do what
they say and that's the same for another
trillion dollars worth of buying on
bitcoin same problem you don't have that
problem i have that problem so when you
think about this um
the bitcoin that ends up getting mined
that
meets all the milestones on this esg
kind of talk track why are people not
willing to pay more for it i think at
one point there was a thought process
and maybe we just haven't seen will they
or not but it seems like folks
they want that bitcoin but from an
economic standpoint i haven't seen
anyone paying more for it so one have i
guess have you seen anyone pay more for
it and then two do you think that's
something that will happen or do you
think that uh that's unlikely to happen
in the future
you know at the beginning of this
journey i thought it might happen that
there'd be some kind of wrapper on clean
coin versus non-clean coin i don't
believe that anymore i think you need
fungibility across every single coin all
21 million of them and i think what's
going to happen is for incremental
buying coming in and i'm saying a
trillion dollars if the if if if my
clients just the institutional and
sovereign funds alone and not not all
mine but that whole asset class of
investor
just did
a one percent allocation towards just
bitcoin that's a trillion dollars worth
of buying so we really really want to
solve this problem as an industry so
it's not because you you get on one side
of the debate or the other they simply
can't check the box and invest until
their compliance committee say yes so
all of these new mining operations so
what i think is going to happen is you
got the existing coin out there now
providence known or not known got it but
if you're setting up a new operation to
mine coin for the next 30 years
you're going to get a lot of
institutional interest in that
infrastructure cost let's say it cost
you half a billion bucks to set up in
west texas you could you could probably
fund that if you guaranteed those
institutions that every coin awarded
would go on the balance sheet stay there
and they could claim to their compliance
committees it was mined sustainably
through wind and solar which you can do
in west texas so that's and you know
you've got the china thing shutting down
you've got all these compliance issues
in eastern europe all of this stuff is
happening in the background and it
started you know the height of this
frenzy was in miami at bitcoin 2021 when
you saw that debate raging and elon musk
said he wouldn't take it anymore for
payment on tesla all of that stuff was
happening at the same time issue hasn't
gone away on the other hand i see it as
a huge upside potential to solve the
problem i want to be long bitcoin when
that one percent gets allocated to the
rest of the funds because that's when
you're going to see really incr amazing
incremental valuations so today we're
sitting around 45 46 000 when that
trillion dollars gets allocated any
thoughts in terms of what happens to
bitcoin
katie bar the doors pump i mean it
depends how fast they come in
i mean that's when you get extreme
extension of valuation you just don't
know anytime people say oh i know the
ceiling on the price of bitcoin they
have no idea it could go anywhere and
it's just because
it depends and here's really what i'm
when i talk to institutions there's a
change in
philosophy about their thinking let's
just stay with bitcoin
bitcoin used to be considered for many
institutions that hadn't owned it yet
the ones that were just looking at it as
a currency
they're not thinking that way anymore
they're looking at it as a property
so you would buy it in the same way as a
aaa office tower in manhattan you buy an
allocation to coin that you're allowed
to own you never trade it you own it as
an asset you know it's compliant it
checks the box
you own it on your balance sheet your
providence
and
it's something that you can own as
property and that's where i think we're
going some percentage will still be
traded
but for the big institutions coming in
this is an asset class that is a
property i think i just heard kevin
o'leary say that bitcoin's price is
unlimited that's what i think i heard
but who knows
[Laughter]
in terms of public companies putting it
on their balance sheet we know
microstrategy tesla square we also know
a number of the uh bitcoin or kind of
crypto focus companies in the public
market have done this as well is that
something where you expect over the next
year or two more and more publicly
traded companies will start to put this
on the balance sheet or are you thinking
more exclusively this stays in kind of
the investment organization uh corner of
the financial market for now
i'll tell you pragmatically what it's
going to take to get the s p 500 putting
an allocation to their treasury and
their balance sheets because you know
they are interested in in starting to
explore crypto
in exchange for cash reserves and we'll
go into that in a second on usdc okay
but let's just stay on bitcoin
that letter that larry fink puts out
every quarter
that dictates uh blackrock's positioning
uh for sustainability we got to solve
for that we got to get larry on board
for bitcoin on a sustainability model
and if he's okay with it because that
letter actually sets policy
for
bo think about the way this works for
sovereign funds who he's the largest
asset manager in the world
and for domestic pension plans and for
universities and everybody else
you start he started this a few years
ago with the sustainability issue and
all of a sudden you saw the market
capitalization of hydrocarbons like oil
companies start to get crushed because
if you're an institution let's say
you've got you know five billion dollars
under management black rock and larry's
telling you look we're not investing in
hydrocarbon distribution companies
anymore whatever his edict is
they're going to be selling those
and so what we need is is
you know i'm just i'm calling out for
the the guy that really sets the
standard it's larry fink in that letter
and his esg committee and the
consultants he uses we've got to get
them on board and if he said look you
want to own bitcoin
this is how you can own it
and still fit the metrics around global
sustainability that's where we're at now
i've taken it upon myself because i'm
not ready yet i want to go there and see
his team and say look i'm going to bring
a bunch of representatives from the
mining community we got to talk
i mean i want to be an investor in
mining i don't want to be offside in
compliance i don't want to be outside on
esg i can't i don't have that option i
can't go against
that mandate
so i'd rather get them on board what
happens if you and i go see larry fink
at blackrock you've got your nice suit
on and your expensive watch and i show
up dressed like this do you think that
he takes the meeting
i think he takes the meeting i think
larry's a pretty pragmatic guy i work in
the institutional world you know that
pomp that's where i am every day and so
you know
i'm sure that you know and i think
probably and i'm just speculating now
because i haven't done my due diligence
yet but i'm going to guess that inside
of his organization
there is a sustainability committee
that's setting up these mandates and
help publishing that quarterly letter
but you got to understand something pomp
that letter is it it is actually policy
that's what that is it's not officially
policy but every institution reads that
letter the institutional committees read
that letter on sustainability and they
try and abide by it because lara is a
pragmatic guy that's where we're at in
the mining community right now we gotta
we gotta solve this you wanna see
bitcoin in a million bucks a coin you
gotta solve this is larry think in your
opinion the most important person in
terms the institutional capital to flow
into the market if larry fink kind of
capitulated put together this uh
framework and said okay here's how to do
it do you think that that would be the
the inflection point
he is the most influential why because
numbers don't lie he's the number one
asset manager on earth every geography
works with him all around the world and
so look i'm just calling it what it is
he's the big dog and he's put the
sustainability man that's out there and
every industry you should talk to the
guys in oil and gas they're not exactly
happy
yeah it makes sense you uh last time
told me that you had made a investment
in a defy uh company and that you were
starting to really spend more time kind
of pushing into that understanding it uh
starting to do all sorts of things
around yield generation what exactly are
you doing there in the update
yeah sure i mean so met this wonderful
team uh in vancouver canada uh brought
to me by some of my guys we look at a
lot of deals obviously you're aware of
that
and um
let me talk about the problem i do a lot
of work in consumer goods and services a
lot of the stuff i do in financial
services is is for the consumer model
for the large not you know for trying to
figure out how to solve a problem for
100 million users not 10.
so
here's a classic case
i have a team here that actually can
write contracts on all the different
platforms when i want to do interest
income on let's say usdc
that that's not easy to do you don't
snap your fingers and do that you've got
to actually do it and i have to do it on
a compliant basis so i have to have all
the reporting i have to do the 1099s
i've got to do all of the mark to market
positions every day and i got a whole
team of people doing that and i've put a
lot of our cash to work that we we sold
off a lot of real estate in the last two
years out of commercial real estate and
now we're putting it it's sitting in
cash making 20 basis points in usd all i
have to do is go usdc and i can start
writing contracts which i am doing now
on 30 60 90 days making about 3.2
percent we wrote contracts this morning
now that's not easy so my daughter who's
27 who's got a bank account at a big
money center bank says hey daddy i'm
getting nothing on my cash i'm getting
18 basis points and you're making three
and a half
how much for that doggie in the window
and i said to her savannah it's a
nightmare you're never going to figure
this out you're not going to get set up
to do this it's not easy to do
she needs an app on her phone
that she can simply say go fetch
move over 1400 bucks out of her you know
her bank account set it up in a series
of contracts
get an accounting basis so that she can
actually report to the irs at the end of
the year get a 1099
that's what wonder phi is that company
started
as d5 ventures and i said to the team
there look let's take advantage of all
the people that know mr wonderful this
is a ripoff of richard branson he does
everything virgin i'm doing everything
wonderful we renamed the company
wonderfuy we raised a ton of money for
it and now it's working on its
applications and i'm luckily be able to
launch it soon and it's going to solve
that problem savannah has she all her
friends and another 100 million people
because there's not enough ease of use
right yet yet in crypto or in d5 and
that's what i'm trying to solve i am
blown away at the fact that two three
years ago you were forbidding me from
doing this and now you're the one who's
telling your daughter to get into it i
love it
[Laughter]
well you know
is interesting it's a bit you know it's
it's a way that you can actually if you
understand what you're doing there it's
a less volatile crypto you know what it
is and you can actually write contracts
on it and get a decent yield at least
more than inflation if inflation is 2.1
percent you got to make three otherwise
you're losing money each year that's my
thinking on it and usdc is the way to do
it but yeah you know i have really had a
major turnaround on crypto you were part
of it i remember being on the set of
cnbc with you in squawk box and barking
at you like a dog but at that time the
regulator was barking like a dog too if
you recall and so i didn't want to be
outside on that now we have a much more
let's call it laissez-faire environment
but you still have to be compliant you
still have to report you still have to
mark to market you can't be a cowboy
about it yeah it makes uh makes a ton of
sense when you think about just the
broader market you mentioned inflation
um and kind of crypto a lot of people
jump when they think of crypto and
public companies to put bitcoin on the
balance sheet right and i think that
there's obviously some that have done it
some that will do it is there a middle
ground where this usdc strategy that
you're employing you'll see some public
companies start to do that as well and
it's merely a low risk volatile value
kind of high yield generation type
strategy from like a treasury management
rather than try to jump straight from us
dollars to bitcoin
you know it's that's a great question
and that is the question well i do
questions
no no but that i'll tell you why that's
a great question because when you go to
the actual compliance departments of
large institutions and i've had many of
these dialogues just in the last you
know two weeks
can you convince your compliance
department that usdc
is not
bitcoin
and that you should somehow get a pass
on usdc versus bitcoin and it shouldn't
be regulated in the same way and that's
where you have a lot of gray zone
because
you know you think about what it if
you're going to be on the treasury side
of your balance sheet let's say you're
managing you know 100 billion dollars of
cash and you want to put a 10 in usdc so
instead of getting 22 basis points you
can get 3.2 percent
and you go to compliance and say i'm
going to take this cash
and convert it to usdc and i'm going to
start writing contracts on it
what do you think the compliance
department's going to tell you they're
going to say
wait a second have we ever done this
before show me where
show me where you got the sign off on
that from the board show me where you
did the reporting not just internally on
the mark to market but you reported
successfully to the irs on the quarterly
and annual basis
the problem isn't that the product isn't
desired the problem is there's no
infrastructure for compliance yet you
know
and you know pomp we're not talking
about small dough here we're talking
about hundreds of millions of dollars
moving fluidly off balance sheets into
these contracts and the only way you're
going to get that done is prove to
compliance and prove to the regulators
that you can do it in a way that you
stay on side so the good news is from
from a institutional guy in terms of my
thinking
what an opportunity what a huge
huge opportunity this is for somebody or
me or multiple platforms
to solve this
for the trillions of dollars that want
to use it if you like that video where
did you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe